And now it's time for tonight's
#HashtagWars.
WATERS:
Holy (bleep).
(applause and cheering)
Since we're here tonight
with the brilliant folks
from Drunk History who get drunk
and teach history,
we felt that we should take
a moment to remember
the towering figures who
got drunk and made history.
For example, we all know
that Winston Churchill
beat the (bleep)
out of the Nazis,
but did you know it was because
the Nazis bumped into him
at a bar and said his cigar
made him look gay?
-Look at that.
-(laughter)
There he is.
There's even, uh, there's even
a meme of this, uh,
adorable drunk little baby.
So, comedians,
in honor of the contribution
of drunks in our past,
tonight's hashtag
is #DrunkerHistory.
Examples might be,
Long Island Iced Tea Party,
or Madam Hangover Curie.
I'm gonna put 06 seconds
on the clock. And begin.
Mae!
-Tweet a picture of your D-Day.
-HARDWICK: Yes, points!
HARDWICK:
Rich Fulcher.
-Abraham Drinkin.
-HARDWICK: Yes, points.
Mae Whitman.
Uh, Last Call of the Mohicans.
HARDWICK:
Yes, points.
Derek Waters.
-Wine-11, always forget.
-HARDWICK: Points.
(laughter, applause)
Derek.
Taking Jell-O shots
off her grassy knoll.
-HARDWICK: All right, points.
-WHITMAN: Wow.
HARDWICK:
Mae.
My personal hero,
Boozin B. Anthony.
HARDWICK:
Yes, points.
Rich Fulcher.
Judge Mojito in the O.J. trial.
HARDWICK:
All right, points.
Judge Mojito.
Very good.
Derek Waters.
Harriet sleepin' in my tub, man.